[Musique]
c'était une journée de terreur
aujourd'hui à ottawa au moins un tireur
a littéralement placer la capitale du
canada en état de siège parce que les
militaires sont devenus une cible
évidente
vous comprendrez que la ville est sous
le choc les militaires aussi à cause de
la mort du caporal est une cyril au
crime ou villes prises
un incendie majeur à isle verte dans une
résidence pour personnes âgées est situé
en plein coeur de la municipalité près
d'une rivière du loup d'ailleurs lé
incendie est toujours en cours au total
les 25 antennes de personnes qui se
trouvaient dans cette résidence pour
personnes âgées
deux enquêtes sont présentement en cours
pour comprendre les causes de l'incendié
alors trois agents de la grc juillet
deux autres blessés dans cette fusillade
à moncton
damien bouhours 24 ans est toujours en
cavale
la grc recherche le tireur restent à
l'intérieur portes verrouillées et
vidéos secteur les gens ici qui
s'apprête à passer une deuxième nuit
alors qu'il ya ce tireur qui est
toujours en cavale nigeria une centaine
de jeunes filles ont été enlevés elles
ont été kidnappés par des hommes armés
du groupe radical islamiste boko haram
les djihadistes de l'état islamique en
irak et en levant ont conquis de vastes
régions du nord du pays quel qu'il soit
ne veut pas l'ami le crâne il a été
placé sur un pied d'alerté maximum les
soldats par exemple ici à la base de
paix rival naya sont pour l'instant
enfermé à l'intérieur de leurs bases
parce que leur base est encerclée
actuellement par des soldats russes qui
ont pris position tout autour
l'hypothèse la plus sérieuse est qu'il a
été atteint par un missile sol air
les gens qui étaient sur place disent
avoir entendu d'abord des coups qui ont
été tirés visiblement du sol vous faites
pour savoir qu'il nourrit et nous
répondrons longtemps la température ce
qui passe la frontière
on vérifie leur température et leur
septembre et le losc peut noyer du
grenville ya tellement de choses qui ont
été dites sur monsieur béliveau et
missionnaire passé 60 ans de sa vie avec
l'organisation du canadien et la
carrière et l'immense générosité
transcende les générations
capitaine au capitaine bon voyage avec
le trémolo dans la voix c'était très
touchant
[Applaudissements]